castle was one of ABC's steadiest
performers for years but not anymore
following the fury of head-scratching
headlines and behind-the-scenes problems
the network abruptly cancelled the crime
drama after an eight season run where
did things go wrong well it's
complicated
stana katic was kicked off the show the
first sign that something was amiss on
the set of Castle came in April of 2016
ABC abruptly opted to not review star
stana katic s-- contract friend ninth
season according to Deadline the
decision was made due to quote budgetary
reasons to add more fuel to the fire
sources claim the kadek wasn't even
approached to renegotiate her contract
even the occasional castle viewer was
shocked by the news of Kanaks departure
although the show is named after Nathan
Fillion character Richard Castle Katt
xscape Beckett had become an integral
part of the show storyline moving
forward without Beckett made absolutely
zero sense
sure high-profile cast members leave
shows all the time while considering the
timing of the news plus reports the
Khattak didn't have a say in her exit
the whole thing felt strange if not
suspicious Tamela Jones got the boot to
Kat ex departure from the show was
shocking enough but things got crazier
when another one of castles top female
stars Tamela Jones left the show as well
in all fairness having Jones continued
to appear on castle without kadek didn't
seem plausible since her character
doctor Lanie parish was Becca's close
friend
the duo's departure seemed to suggest
the castle was preparing for a major
storyline shift in season 9 which never
would have worked because the show had
changed too much in its coverage of
kadek shocking departure The Hollywood
Reporter noted that the shake-up could
allow castle to focus more on the show's
weekly crime procedurals instead the
show had been focusing on larger
character arcs relationship troubles and
general drama the show had already
hinted that it was heading in that
direction when Castle and Beckett
separated at the top of season 8 Castle
grew out of its procedural shoes a long
time ago and it's since become a show
that many viewers were invested in
because of its characters returning
Castle to a run-of-the-mill procedural
drama would have set the show back years
fans were expecting it to move forward
given how the firings upset fans and the
shows on cast it's impossible to imagine
castle returning to its roots without
losing viewers did Fillion and khattak
hate each other
amid reports of Caddick sex 'it word got
out that she and Fillion did not get
along on set much to the heartbreak of
castle fans everywhere in fact things
allegedly got so bad that Fillion would
often make how to cry quotes Tana would
cry on set because Nathan was such a
bully to her a source told Us Weekly
just days after kx-- departure hit the
wires added a second source quotes Tana
will go into her dressing room and cry a
lot of people who work for the show
don't like Nathan it's not just her
nathan has been nasty to stand up for a
long time
Stano was a pro just wanted to get in
there and do her job a rep for Caddick
denied any onset tension Fillion dodged
the rumors but his template I wish her
well reaction on Twitter led many fans
to wonder if the reports were actually
true ratings were sluggish when you
remove all of the behind-the-scenes
drama from castle ABC's decision to
cancel the show might have been a lot
more rational than we initially thought
the show would simply not been pulling
the kind of ratings that he used to the
season 8 premiere debuted to just under
7 million viewers down about 4 million
viewers from the previous season those
numbers were likely an especially tough
pill for ABC execs to swallow
since castle once averaged more than 12
million viewers but the bleeding didn't
stop there in February 2016 castle aired
its midseason premiere 25.7 2 million
viewers a series low according to TVLine
by that point the show was already in
ABC's crosshairs new show runners were
brought in another obvious sign that
castles time was running out the series
hired new show runners Alexi Hawley and
Terrence Paul winner to take the reins
in season 8 hiring new people to run a
show this late in the game is never a
great sign it's even worse that they
made risky changes to the storyline only
to backtrack a few episodes later such
was the case with Castle and Beckett
separation amid outrage from fans Holly
and winter were forced to go on the
defense assuring everyone that nobody
was actually getting divorce
but when Castle and Beckett got back
together by taking their relationship on
the DL even that felt forced unnecessary
and uncreated it seemed like castles new
showrunners we're running with scissors
the show could not survive the negative
press between Khattak sex it rumors of
bad blood on set and the ratings in the
toilet castle limped to the finish line
with a kind of bad press that no show
could shake even if Castle had returned
for a ninth season the show would have
spent the entire time dealing with the
fallout of getting rid of their main
characters it also would have spent a
good chunk of time contending with the
bad press which no doubt would have
ballooned the moment the show took
another dip in ratings in other words by
pulling the plug on Castle now ABC saved
itself from fighting a battle it was
never gonna win sad as it may sound it
was safer to go out on a low note rather
than while scraping the absolute bottom
of the barrel thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know why you think Castle was really
cancelled